[Music]  only in the between frozen co-stars  Kristen Bell and Adina Michelle yes but  that did not stop Kristen from pulling  one awesome sisterly single off what did  you think I thought that if my voice  sounds nice coming out of her beautiful  face parents Queen Elsa is back she's  part of the 21 minute short Olaf's  frozen adventure that will hit theatres  along with Disney's new animated feature  Coco let the holidays begin is there an  update on frozen - yeah we've begun  working on it and that's all I can  really tell you that's it's nice to kind  of go in the studio you know make up and  play you know but prepare your kids  they'll have to wait until November 2019  for frozen - to hit heaters what is it  like to be a part of a movie that your  kid can actually see that's funny cuz my  kid doesn't always want to see mommy and  in her movie but one day you'll think  I'm cool right